this is Startalk hi I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson I'm an astrophysicist with the
American Museum of Natural History right
here in New York City and I host
Startalk welcome back to star talk radio
and it's fighting all these air
molecules like what's up with that we
win astrophysicist so Obama wants to
lassu an asteroid here's the problem the
spaceships we now have can't reach where
the asteroids hang out but he made a
speech a few years ago that we're gonna
send astronauts to an asteroid and so
since our ships that we're building
can't reach the asteroid we're gonna
bring an asteroid to where the ship can
reach it and so in the in the space of
the moon in orbit around the moon we're
gonna tow an asteroid to that location
then bring our spaceships there and you
kind of want to know how to move
asteroids around that's a good thing to
be able to do because one day we're
gonna find one with our name on it
a big bad asteroid and I don't want to
sit here and just say wrong I want to be
able to deflect it as the asteroids get
slark get larger and larger we will not
be able to move them in that way we have
to be more creative and on paper we have
ideas about how to deflect asteroids
with rockets with a nuclear blast
there are a lot of inventive ways to
deflect asteroids and they're still
being sort of hashed out at scientific
conferences my favorite is the
gravitational tractor beam that's where
you take it take an S to you on the
asteroid right and you get a spaceship
what's a good spaceship here is a
spaceship and it comes up to me and then
you park it there this is our spaceship
and it's tiny compared with the big bad
asteroid you park it there and they'll
want to move towards one another because
they'll feel each other's gravity but
you don't let that happen you fire retro
rockets and the act of doing that slowly
tugs the asteroid out of its harmful
path towards Earth that's the kind leur
gentler way yeah we got people who
wanted to blow the sucker out of the sky
we got nukes still in silos from the
Cold War right and why not put him to
good use but I've always worried in
America we're really good at blowing
stuff up
we're just less good at knowing where
the pieces will fall so if there's an
asteroid headed straight towards Earth
and we blow it to smithereens
but all those smithereens still hit
Earth that's still a bad day on earth
so I just like to deflect it and that's
a the Obama plan is a first step in that
direction
you